aujourd'hui je vous aide à choisir votre
macbook que vous n'en ayez pas et que
vous décidiez de vouloir partir sur mac
ce que je comprends parfaitement ou
alors vous en avez déjà et il est temps
de le renouveler
et vous vous posez la question de savoir
quel mac book acheter un macbook air
macbook pro quelle configuration entre
les deux et surtout par quel canal de
vente ou l'acheter pour trouver la
meilleure affaire le meilleur prix est
d'abord derrière les meilleures
garanties alors je vais vous aider à
vous expliquer tout ça pour vous
permettre de trouver votre macbook au
meilleur prix mais avant toute chose
aujourd'hui c'est une vidéo qui réalise
en partenariat avec clint go pour
protéger votre mac contre toutes les
bandes extérieures
je sais pas si vous connaissez des
gosses et l'entreprise existe depuis
1997 ça fait un petit moment et qui
protège les mac c'est une entreprise
leader dans la protection de mac et
aujourd'hui je vous parle de la solution
intego mac premium bundle xf le nom est
un petit peu à coucher dehors mais la
solution est intéressante
il vous propose pas moins de cinq outils
pour venir sécuriser votre mac pour vous
protéger de différentes manières vous
allez trouver notamment des russes
barrière qui est un des meilleurs
antivirus sur mac va vous protéger
contre beaucoup de adware malware
spyware ça fait beaucoup de norway r
dans l'idée ce qu'il faut savoir que ça
va bien vous protéger contre tous les
virus que vous allez pouvoir retrouver
de façon un peu globale sur mac sur
internet
vous avez également des barrières qui
est un firewall keita pare feu qui va
venir vous protéger contre toutes les
connexions entrantes si une personne
tierce cherche à s'introduire dans votre
ordinateur elles devaient être bloquées
et c'est une application quelle qu'elle
soit chasse collecte internet on vous
demandait une autorisation pour vous
puissiez l'autoriser ou pas à se
connecter au réseau
il ya également personal backup qui va
faire des sauvegardes de votre
ordinateur et vous propose des outils
encore plus puissant que ce que vous y
retrouver avec time machine
c'est à vous offrir plus de flexibilité
dans vos sauvegardes et vous pourrez
même créer une sauvegarde bootable pour
votre mac mais il ya également mac
washing machine c'est une machine à la
dépendance n'a qu' on revenir optimiser
l'espace libre pour vous ayez toujours
la plaçant votre ordinateur
et à la fin vous avez comme cette
barrière 6 9 qui est une solution de
contrôle parental
si vous êtes parents voulaient pouvoir
créer chaque profil pour vos enfants à
la maison et leur octroyer les
permissions vous souhaitez vous avez
donc une solution complète pour venir
protéger votre mac contre différentes
attaques vous permettre de le gérer de
façon extrêmement simple pour protéger
votre mac des hackers et des malwares je
vous ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description vous pouvez y aller c'est
juste en dessous revenons-en à nos
moutons son histoire de macbook c'est
très intéressant parce que ça soulève
beaucoup de questions on va donc faire
cette vidéo en trois parties
tout est noté ici une mort sanglante et
vous l'été vous allez moi c'est très
simple la première partie c'est savoir
qu'elles sont vous
quels sont vos besoins donc qu'elle
typologie de macbook est fait pour vous
nike book air macbook pro on va
redéfinir sa par rapport à vos usages
actuels mais également par rapport à
votre usage futur
le deuxième point c'est quelle
configuration choisir sur l'une ou
l'autre des machines on va tous détaillé
et pour ça regardez les gens qui
truquent là j'ai fait une espèce de
tableaux sont engagés tous noté on va se
regarder ça dans quelques instants et
vous allez voir c'est cool il ya plein
de choses à dire et la troisième
question c'est la partie de l'achat
est-ce que vous allez acheter un produit
neuf un produit d'occasion reconditionné
à quel endroit et potentiellement à quel
tarif est à la fois cette vidéo vous
devriez savoir quel mac book acheter on
va tout recommencer pour la partie des
besoins et des usages puisque si on veut
acheter une machine c'est pour en faire
quelque chose à bord une machine avec
beaucoup de performances et des grosses
paix qu'en gros disque dur ça ne vous
servira globalement pas forcément grand
chose ça fait pas partie de vos besoins
actuels et potentiellement des besoins
futurs que vous pourriez avoir parce que
si vous achetez un mac book vous vous
dites que vous allez garder entre 5 à 10
ans en fonction de vous de vos besoins
mais également en fonction de la durée
de vie de la machine
bon ça serait à peu près dans cette
durée là beaucoup aujourd'hui posez vous
la question quels sont vos besoins pour
moi je vois deux grandes familles de
besoin la première famille des besoins
c'est plus de la bureautique aller sur
internet
relevé des mails prise de notes pour des
étudiants vous avez besoin de
performance ne faisait pas besoin de
trop de performance besoin d'une belle
machine qui fonctionnera bien mais vous
n'avez pas besoin du foudre de guerre
puisque vous n'avez pas des applications
qui sont extrêmement gourmandes pour ce
produit là je vous conseillerais
réellement d'aller sur un macbook air si
maintenant vous en avez un usage
professionnel c'est-à-dire que vous
faites par exemple comme moi de la vidéo
et que vous avez besoin de puissance et
besoins de performance si vous faites de
la 3d que vous avez besoin de beaucoup
de performance derrière si on règle
générale vous êtes créatif sur de la
photo photoshop lightroom et plein
d'autres logiciels
eh bien vous avez besoin de performance
vous avez besoin d'une machine qui va
vous suivre tu vas pouvoir aller partout
est tout terrain en fonction de tous mes
besoins et il faut surtout que vous vous
posez pas la question est ce que ma
bécane pas pouvoir supporter ça oui ou
non doit être transparent flûte en os
marché quelles que soient les choses que
vous allez lui demander pour ça nous
avions dû machines professionnelles vous
allez donc aller dans la gamme macbook
pro vous
donc vos besoins aujourd'hui posez vous
la question des besoins de vous allez
avoir lutté rieur mans puisque
aujourd'hui si vous êtes étudiant peut
être que dans un an deux ans trois ans
vous allez avoir des nouveaux besoins
anticiper les besoins de vous allez
avoir à l'avenir
et est ce que la configuration de votre
machine telle qu'elle est là aujourd'hui
suffira est ce que vous allez avoir
besoin de changer de machine parce que
potentiellement vous allez avoir le
budget dans les temps à venir ce que
vous devez dès maintenant acheter une
machine qui servira également pour plus
tard il existe différents modèles
macbook air macbook pro on va maintenant
se poser la question de la config on
voit ces affaires version profs alors je
sais que c'est pas hyper hyper pratique
j'espère vous voyez bien quand même ce
qu'il écrit si c'est pas le cas je
voudrais capituler et si on est sur le
macbook air de 2020 macbook air version
un peu classique macbook pro 13 pouces
macbook pro 15 pouces macbook pro 13
pouces devant ma belle ducati comme ça
on est plutôt bien équipée et la plus
compliquée la sortir l'un confinement
faisons ceci étant dit on va voir
plusieurs points le premier point ici
c'est la version du processeur on va
parler de la ram a parlé du stockage et
on va parler du times ok c'est pas hyper
pratique j'ai pas beaucoup de place mais
j'ai quand même essayé de faire comme ça
qu'est ce qu'il faut savoir sur le
macbook air 2020 c'est qu'apple nous
apporte ce qu'ils savent faire de mieux
sur leur macbook air par rapport à ce
que vous aviez à l'hôte macbook air qui
est ce côté là et qui n'est pas le
macbook air 2020 dans tous les cas sur
tous les produits que vous présente
vous avez des écrans retina trou tonnes
ça c'est acté cette base ici au niveau
du macbook air 2020 sur la partie
processeur vous avez trois possibilités
il croit que vous allez trouver à 1199
euros
si vous voulez un i5 il faut rajouter 50
euros et si vous voulez à issel faut
rajouter 130 euros je vous conseille dès
le départ de partir minimum sur un i5
vous avez quatre coeurs et n'ont pas de
coeur pour moi c'est le strict minimum
qui vous pouvez monter oui cette fonte
gagner un petit peu en vitesse de calcul
au niveau de la ram
vous avez soit 8 soit 16 giga de ram ici
la ram c'est la lpddr2 4x on le retient
par rapport à notre modèle de macbook
air ici en stockage vous avez soit 256
giga 512 1 tera ou de terrain et vous
commencez au tarif de 1199 euros
seul macbook air 2020 vous aviez sur des
options le tarif ne vous annonce ici à
1199 euros
ces souris version 8 gigas de ram 256 go
de stockage si vous voulez passer sur le
16 giga de ram il faut rajouter 250
euros et si vous montez en stockage 512
plus de 150 1 tera plus 500 2 tera +1000
déjà sur une config de base pour de la
bureautique à 1199 euros en 256 go de
stockage et 8 gigas de ram temps de la
bureautique que la bureautique saga saw
macbook air de 2020 vous
chaque dit vous n'avez pas de touch
barre mais surtout vous avez un point
essentiel et qui est pour moi un des
arguments les plus importants pour cette
machine là c'est que vous avez le magic
qui ben je sais pas si vous connaissiez
un petit peu les anciens produits
d'apple est bien peu là souvent été
critiqué sur ses produits et dernières
années parce que la vie papillon n'était
pas extraordinaire ils ont vraiment tout
corrigé et amélioré sur leurs derniers
modèles en intégrant le magic qui
bordent qui marche vraiment bien que ce
soit sur le macbook air de 2020 ou sur
le macbook pro c'est pousser ça croyez
moi c'est vraiment important surtout si
vous avez eu des galères avec le clavier
papillon vous savez quoi je parle après
si c'est son tarif ça coince pour
alexandre macbook air 2020 vous êtes sur
le macbook air de génération précédente
alors attention ici la ramènera un peu
moins vite vous avez de la lp ddr3 et
non pas de l'alpe est dédié à 4x vous
avez une 1ère config à 128 go de
stockage que je vous déconseille
complètement parce qu'avec 100 étudiants
de stockage et bien vous n'avez pas
pouvoir mettre grand chose dedans
puisque votre os prendre la place et
tout le reste les applications je vous
le déconseille vous ne rien pouvoir
stocker vous allez galéré très
rapidement pour moi le grand minimum et
le grand grand grand minimum ses 250 iga
de stockage il se pouvait monter jusqu'à
512 ça c'est vraiment bien donc si vous
voulez un macbook destinée bureautique
et vous n'avez pas besoin de beaucoup de
performances
le macbook air de 2020 et très bien
maintenant on va se parler du macbook
pro 13 pouces j'avais de config i5 i7
prendre le bus est il faut rajouter 375
euros vous avez 8 ou 16 giga de ram pour
monter ce biais de renforts ajouter 250
euros et leur stockage vont commencer
par 128 mais vraiment je vous le
déconseille 256 faut rajouter 250 euros
512 pour ajouter 500 euros un terrain
fort injuste et 750 et 2 tera faut
rajouter 1250 et leurs gardes et les
configs au niveau des tarifs sur les
deux premières vous avez deux ports
snowball 3 soit troisième avec 4 ports
son envol 3 la première 1499 teint il
5,8 +128 128 c'est vraiment trop petit
pour moi faut regarder au minimum la
deuxième 1749 7 à 5,8 plus de 156 si
vous avez un i5 à 1999 euros avec 4
ports moi c'est parce que je vous
conseille surtout qu'ici vous avez de la
ram c'est la lp ddr3 vous avez d intel
core de huitième génération moi ce que
je vous conseille d'aller sur le macbook
air 2020 où vous avez d intel core 2 10e
génération est lassé de la lpddr2 4x
vous allez avoir une rame qui va
fonctionner beaucoup plus vite vous avez
des processeurs plus récent pour avoir
un 5 vous montez vous rajouter 50 euros
vous êtes à 1250 euros 8 plus de 156
tandis que la à 1500 euros vous êtes sur
5,8 +128 pour moi même ou pro 13 pouces
est un produit qui commence quand même
vraiment à vieillir je conseille
vraiment d'aller sur le macbook air 2020
magic qui bordent même sûre d'elle non
professionnels pour un 13 pouces je
conseille vraiment le macbook air vous
le booster et en termes de performances
intra parfaitement la ferme maintenant
se pose la question des modèles 15 et 16
pouces vous voulez vraiment de la
machine professionnelle si vous avez
vraiment des besoins de performance vous
voulez un grand écran de 15 ou 16 pouces
si vous avez besoin d'une machine
endurante machine va pouvoir répondre à
tout ce que vous allez lui demander
là on se pose vraiment sur ce qu apple
nous propose de mieux mais quel produit
choisir entre le macbook pro 15 pouces
et le macbook pro 13 pouces
j'ai faut savoir de base les macbook pro
13 pouces est présenté au même tarif que
le macbook pro 15 pouces donc si vous
devez choisir du neuf
allez sur le macbook pro 16 pouces de
toute façon sur le site d'apple le
macbook pro 15 pouces les plus
disponibles
vous pourrez trouver ailleurs mais
vraiment celui là je vous conseille non
pas par la taille de l'écran vous le
verrez dans mon test qui va pas changer
vraiment grand chose mais vous avez
vraiment une amélioration notamment au
niveau de l'audio cette machine a
vraiment un très bon son mais surtout
c'est le magic qui bordent qui lire
vraiment changé l'histoire par rapport
aux claviers papillon et croyez moi
c'est vraiment important moi j'ai les 2
g le macbook pro 15 pouces les macbook
pro 16 pouces le clavier papillon et le
magic qui bordent
il ya vraiment une différence alors
maintenant la question de la config son
macbook pro 13 pouces besson en intel
core i7 sont les neuf si vous voulez les
neuf qu'il faut rajouter 380 euros
vous avez aussi le choix au niveau des
cartes graphiques amd radeon pro 5300 m
+ 4 gigas de mémoire dédiée vous pouvez
changer monter au modèle supérieur la
5500m toujours à 4 gigas plus 125 euros
ou alors vous avez carrément sur l'a5
1500m plus 8 giga dédié à plus de 150
euros
ça va vraiment dépendre de vos besoins
en termes de graphisme 16 giga de ram de
base 8 ce serait vraiment trop trop
court pour un usage professionnel 32 ou
64 moi je vous conseille si vous pouvez
passer de 32 à plus 500 euros c'est un
budget est un modèle professionnel faut
pas hésiter à augmenter sa config pour
penser vraiment l'avenir 512 de stockage
de base c'est beaucoup trop court
notamment si vous faites de la vidéo
partez sur un grand minimum
deux terrains pourquoi pas 4 8 ou
vraiment avoir des besoins tous de
tarifs s'envolent la config de base
il commence à 2199 euros avec un intel
core i7 16 giga de ram 512 ya du
stockage moi ce que je conseille de
partir là dessus à 3829 grand minimum
avec un 19 32 gigas de ram et un terrain
de stockage parce qu'on est toujours
dans la même réflexion penser à l'avenir
pensez à vos usages de demain
quelles vont être vos besoins et sur une
machine comme ça une machine que vous
allez payer quand même cher plus de 3000
euros
je vous conseille dès maintenant de vous
poser la question de qu'est-ce que vous
allez potentiellement faire dans trois à
cinq ans je sais que c'est dur te
projeter mais c'est extrêmement
important
ne vous laissez pas dépasser par la
technologie ne vous laissez pas dépasser
par la ram si vous faites de la vidéo 32
gigas de ram c'est pas un luxe et 64 à
serait encore mieux si vous avez des
projets qui sont un peu lourds vous
montez en 4k pourquoi pas en 8k on m'a
fait une démo sur le live by cas là
dessus ça tourne mais il faut vraiment
de la ram il vous faut du stockage
derrière ça sans doute c'est trop peu
j'ai mon macbook pro 15 pouces qui a 512
je suis tout le temps en train de
transférer sur un disque dur externe au
pouvoir rien porter les projets c'est
une galère un terrain c'est le minimum
de tera c'est quand même beaucoup mieux
bien évidemment ça dépend des bourses de
chacun on n'a pas forcément les moyens m
3500 4000 4500 euros dans un ordinateur
mais dites vous bien que c'est un outil
professionnel c'est un investissement
professionnel est une machine que vous
allez garder dans le temps c'est pour ça
que c'est vraiment la différence entre
le macbook air qui est plus le fait de
vouloir avoir un mac un bon back une
bonne machine mais sur lequel moi faire
de la bureautique avec des besoins pas
trop exigeants et la différence avec
ordinateur vraiment professionnel son
enquête par contre là il faut tout de
suite mettre les moyens dès le départ
pour pouvoir travailler tranquillement
maintenant et anticiper les besoins à
venir et le macbook pro 15 pouces me
direz vous et bien si vous ne trouvez
pas trop cher il ya également le clavier
papillon c'est parce que je vous
conseillerais comment pas d'un outil
professionnel
on parle d'un investissement il faut pas
hésiter directement sur le macbook pro
13 pouces
vous avez touché skype physique aussi
bon moi ça c'est du point de détail
peuvent ouvrir la question des ports est
ce que 2 ports thunderbolt roi vous
suffiront comme sur le macbook air ou
est ce qu il vous en faut quatre comme
sur un macbook pro moi personnellement
j'en utilise deux le premier pour la
charge
le deuxième pour nous à brancher mon
petit dock pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui
vous n'avez que des ports thunderbolt
roi autant dire que vous
manqué beaucoup de choses et c'est des
fois qu'on revient peut regretter donc
du coup j'ai toujours mon dock avec moi
là j'ai mon petit lecteur de cartes
microsd sd pour venir décharger mon
appareil bon boîtier tout simplement
j'ai toujours un petit disque dur pour
faire des petites sauvegarde rapide et
là j'en ai un deuxième sur le sud ne
mangeait pas et la voyez j'ai mon petit
homme sur lequel tout vient se brancher
donc j'ai toujours ça avec moi dans mon
sac à dos les cauchois studio à paris je
moniteur quatre cas avec une prise usb
ces jeunes branchés donc j'ai besoin
minimum de 4 triste normale-3 vraiment
aussi se poser cette question là
maintenant que vous savez quel mac book
vous souhaitez acheter et que vous avez
une vision globale sur la configuration
que vous avez besoin ou est-ce que vous
allez acheter cette machine et de quelle
manière
usuellement je dirais ok je vais aller
acheter mon macbook directement chez
apple il ya des apple store vous pouvez
également l'acheter en ligne d'apple
mais aussi d'autres vendeurs avec
derrière la garantie apple vous avez
absolument aucun problème
fnac darty boulanger et compagnie
cdiscount jouait d'ailleurs des liens en
bas d'un description si vous souhaitez
changer votre macbook pro que vous
invite à faire un petit tour par ses
liens là sont bien sûr des liens
d'affiliation
mais vous pouvez également acheter votre
produit en reconditionnés c'est à dire
un produit qui a déjà taillé sur marché
et qui a été renvoyée apple propose du
reconditionnés sur son site web
vous allez tout en bas vous allez
trouver des produits reconditionnés à
des tarifs extrêmement intéressant alors
il ya tout il n'y a pas forcément les
tout d'un des produits quoique fait
vraiment attention aux configurations à
la date à laquelle a été mille produits
sur le marché vous est donc savoir si
c'est un produit qui est récent ou qui
n'est pas récent posez vous toujours la
question comme je voulais dire quelle
machine pour quels usages quelle
configuration par rapport à mes besoins
actuels et à mes besoins à venir
et voyez s'il ya un tarif qui pourrait
vous convenir via le refurb
sachez que si vous achetez en réforme
notamment sur le site d'apple vous
bénéficiez quand même de deux ans de
garantie 1an garantie apple la deuxième
année de garantie c'est la garantie
europe et donc vous êtes couverts
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura aidé
à y voir un peu plus clair sur la
méthode en toi qui me semble être la
mienne c'est comme ça que fonctionne
pour savoir quel mac book acheter et
quel produit restera le général
j'applique toujours cette méthode
mésusage la config est ensuite ou le
jeter au meilleur prix et par rapport à
mes besoins
quel mac book vous vous souhaitez
acheter vous peut le remarquer en bas en
commentaire et est ce que cette vidéo
vous aura aidé pour tous marqué en bas
et si vous avez des besoins des envies
des idées
allez-y c'est pareil pour marquer en bas
sur ce je vous embrasse vous rendez vous
dès demain pour tilloy par l'etec aller
les bisous à demain ciao
loin des sommets me fais
on ne peut pas par an
tu peux pas tuer
2 1 de sky one the sun